We’ve just hit 4 million subscribers
which means that
we’ll have an epic best of 7 game match
between Otto and Miikka!
Besides from fighting for honor
and this amazing trophy
you guys voted the loser
to face his fear
and jump off a plane
from 4 thousand meters
Who will win this match?
I think it's going to be a good game
We're both in our
top forms
Let's see
Let's see what happens
Good luck!
I think Emil
should guess
who’s gonna win
If he guesses wrong
he also has to jump off a plane!
How did this turn like this?
Why am I in the risk zone?
I'm not even playing
I guess
Miikka will win the match
Two people are going to jump off a plane!
Could be!
Thank you for the trust!
If I lose, I won't have to jump alone
Will you jump with me if I lose?
No, no, no, I’m just gonna film!
It’s intense!
We both know what's on the line!
Loser
falls off a plane
neither of us wants to lose this
Oh, this is exciting!
That's a way to start the game!
He is not messing around!
Started off the match with a bomb!
I'm actually
regretting my choice at the moment...
Emil you’re stuck with me now!
Unfortunately yes...
What’s going on here?
I don’t know!
Otto’s forehand attack
is working pretty well
Backhand as well
Sorry!
Yes!
The first point!
Reassuring
Not everything comes
I'm going home!
Okay the sensei is looking pretty strong!
I have to say!
I played the best backhand!
What was that?
What’s happening actually?!
I don't know what's happening
Otto clearly
doesn't want to jump off a plane
Okay here we come!
Good serve!
Just give him there!
So close!
I should have just
hit it hard!
I have to say
it couldn't be much more
even than this!
What a point!
He’s just standing there!
We’re gonna play best of 7
why would I waste my energy?
Exactly, first game goes to the Sensei!
So we play until four sets!
Haven’t won anything yet
except the first set!
Show your magic!
Let’s do this!
Let
Was it?
Ok it was!
Sorry
No spin from the net!
Zwei - zwei!
How can you focus?
Emil knows that
Miikka you play in Germany!
Danke schön!
Allez allez!
No that was French!
Lederhosen
Very good angle
Easy mistakes!
Second jumper seems to be
not that optimistic anymore
What a point!
And a scream
That was an important miss!
I know!
And another!
It was that one rally
I needed that one
Look at that beautiful
footwork!
I could give you two points for that!
Good placement
The sets
couldn't be more even than this!
I don't know, I missed one
Then Miikka just
kept the ball on table
and I did all the misses
How is your confidence now?
It's better than the first set
He's showed signs that he’s
a human being!
We have a chance here!
Game number three!
Will the Sensei make
sense of his game again
or will Magic Mike
show his magic?
What a point!
Kaboom!
Keep the ball on the table
That's how you win the points!
That's a very good point, actually!
How did he get that back!?
When you have to move
You need to move
Same mistake
It's still not over this set!
It's as over
as it can be
Have to start those
hoh, huh
sounds already
I've got to start doing
some sounds myself
*weird noises*
I don't know what that was Otto
I was trying to go as hard as I could
Interesting!
Was it over the table?
Maybe not
I got a bit scared on that one!
Good shotto!
Now it’s tenn-illä-ven
He put no spin on it!
The banana no spin
The Sensei takes the lead!
Big set
Who's going to get the trophy?
Just keep it on the table!
Main tactic against the sensei!
That's also a good tactic!
Sorry!
Ace serve!
Showing slo-mo replay:
It was almost on the table's leg!
What a point!
Big point!
It's getting intense!
It's very intense!
This is what everybody wants to see!
Nine all!
Oh I had it!
No you didn’t !
I’m more and more optimistic
all the time
about my chances to win this match
I haven't lost hope yet
That was important
I shouldn't serve that serve!
Please serve it again
Free falling!
I'm starting to imagine
the situation when I jump off a plane
Time out!
Just don't give him there
Where do I give him?
Give him in the spot where he isn’t
I'm ready!
You better be
Yeah exactly!
It worked
I wasn't ready for that!
That I was ready for
The pressure is high
It’s a match point!
Thank you.
The well deserved winner trophy!
The Sensei takes the match!
4 Million match
Why did I choose Miikka?
There he is
Guys this is what happens if you lose
Otto is
Enjoying his morning coffee
Imagine yeah
He’s just sleeping
This is the man I’m trusting my life with
Are we gonna make it?
I think so yeah!
Oh no!
Okay!
We’re set!
My heartbeat is actually getting a bit higher
I feel it!
I’ve never seen Emil so pale
Just looking down from here
I’m honestly pretty scared
Our friends are leaving us behind
Bye!
Okay Emil!
Let’s go!
Okay I’m pretty scared
Emil’s off!
I might never see him again
Okay it’s getting real!
It’s really getting real now!
Oh man!
This is crazy!
Let’s go!!
Remember to subscribe!
That was crazy!
That was scary!
That was definitely scary!
I don’t know what I expected but
That was insane!
I see Emil over there
looks like he’s survived too
There is Miikka as well!
Emil!
We made it!
Okay guys
Remember to hit subscribe
This was 4 million special
Can’t wait for 5 million!
Oh my, that’s scary